maire non masculin désignant la personne
qui dirige une commune le maire c'est le
M de James Bond sans et tous ses gadgets
c'est lui qui détient le pouvoir
exécutif et l'autorité municipale
passant continuellement de la fonction
d'agent de l'État à celle d'agent de la
commune au service pas du tout secret de
la République le maire a des missions il
organise les élections célèbre les
mariages enregistre les naissances et
les décès mais le maire c'est aussi
surtout un agent communal c'est même le
001 élu par son conseil municipal pour 6
ans renouvelables un maire ça ne dit pas
que deux fois en tant que tel le maire
applique les délibérations du conseil
c'est lui aussi qui donne le permis de
dépenser qui signe la licence
d'emprunter et qui gère le personnel
communal bref le maire c'est octopussie
mais amè ça n'est pas élu rien que pour
vos yeux il perçoit une indemnité de 646
€ pour une commune de moins de 500
habitants à 5512 € pour les plus de
200000 des m femmes ça existe aussi mais
comme dans les James Bond on les voit
pas beaucoup la nouvelle loi sur la
parité c'est un peu l'opération tonnerre
ça va secouer dans les communes mais au
shaker pas à la
cuillère